أعتقد أنها بحاجة إلى العودة
لأسباب إنسانية وإن لم يكن من
أجلها ومن أجل الطفل لأن
طفلها بريء والآن بعد أن علمنا
أن حقائق
حياة الطفل في أيدي
الجمهور البريطاني  كيف يمكننا أن نقول لا ،
يجب أن تموت مع
والدتك المراهقة الحمقاء السخيفة
، أعتقد أنها صغيرة بما يكفي
وهي صغيرة بما يكفي للتعلم وأنا
أعلم أنها ذكية بما يكفي لتتعلم
لأنها كانت جيدة في المدرسة الثانوية كانت
جيدة  طالبة ولم يكن لديها ما يكفي من
التعرض لامتياز كان لديها ما يكفي من
التعرض للتفكير بنفسها أنها
محاصرة في بيئة حيث يتعين
عليك التفكير بطريقة واحدة لأنه إذا سألت
الله عن طريقة تفكير إيزيس
إذا سألت الله أو سألته
السلطات ، إنها خطيئة ، إنها ردة ،
ولذا يمكنني أن أتخيل الخوف من
أنها حاصرت نفسها عقليًا
لأنها لا تعرف كيف تفكر في نفسها
ولكن يمكننا كسر ذلك يمكننا أن
نعلمها عندما تأتي  يمكننا
إعادة تأهيلها وتعليمها
واقع الحياة